in the 38 years of academy history over
125 actors of won Oscars this year I
wondered again what I've been doing
wrong so I asked some former winners for
a few tips Ingrid Bergman what is the
main factor in an award winning
performance well first of all it is the
part because I don't think any actor can
do an oscar-winning performance without
having the heart and then it's a
question of timing you have to be sure
that that year nobody else has a better
part and of course it's happened quite
often that very good performances come
out the same year and one will lose and
never have a chance to get it again
there are several main factors good part
well-written
well directed well photographed well it
edited and with all that you if you're
not too bad you you're very good
well I think that it's a mixture of saw
so many things together and I think is a
dream of every actress really to win an
Oscar and when you want it you feel that
you have fulfilled all your ambitions
and I must say that the oscar has an
essay encouraged me to peek certain kind
of roles and to abandon some exterior
aspects of them of my physique well my
opinion I would I would think that the
picture itself has a great deal to do
with the act of winning the Oscar role
the Oscar Award if if a film is thought
of as a quality film or as an extremely
popular film in short a very good film
than the actor if he has a good role and
it commends much more attention to often
you see many actors give
and performances and poor films and they
go unnoticed
well you just try to do a good job you
get a roll and you try to think out what
it's about and you go to work that's all
but it I think I did a fair job in that
film and I liked doing it very much well
Jack would you describe your reaction to
the night you won the Oscar well it I
think it was a combination of elation
naturally and realization that the
Academy had exercised extremely good
judgment no seriously it was of course
elation because any time that you get an
accolade from the members of your own
craft it's different than just applause
it's it's the highest accolade that
anybody can get I think if you're a
bricklayer and someone says gee that's a
beautiful house that's one thing if
another bricklayer says boy you lace
well bricks that's the thing that you
remember more than anything else it's
the highest honor that we have within
the business and to receive it is a
great elation I had put myself after the
nomination which i think is just about
an equal honor in a frame of mind a sort
of blase frame of mind in which I had
said well if you don't receive it it's
not important and everything was fine I
was calm cool and collected as I said in
the audience that night and when my name
was Howard out I covered the distance
between me and Oscar about a hundred
yards in 10 seconds flats so I wasn't
very blunt would you believe nine
I really was scared to death to come to
Hollywood and assist at the ceremony
because my reaction whether I had won an
Oscar or not I think I would have
fainted and so I preferred to faint at
home and said in front of so many people
I was so excited then the next morning
or night they are mourning here they
call me and I was thrilled when I wanted
and then a lot of people called me my
agent and all the people in his party Oh
everybody called me and it was it was so
good to win it well by the time that
envelope was up there I didn't such a
state of shock that I think if they
hadn't read my name oz had gone up
anyway and grabbed it and I rushed up
and fell had tripped up those steps on
the right and felt placed on when I find
it got to the microphone I thought I'd
better try and explain this rather
peculiar performance so I meant to say I
was so loaded with Goodluck charms that
I felt but unfortunately I made an idiot
pause after the word loaded and I said
I'm so loaded never laughed I became the
first self-confessed drunk to win
well Olivia do you have any advice for
this year's nominees oh I have advice
for this year's nominees as far as their
opportunity there are chances of winning
is concerned I recommend using a rather
dishonest method it's the method
employed by my sister with unfailing
success when she was nine years old and
I was 10 years old and we used to play
cards during the summer she won every
single round and I discovered what was
her secret weapon it was infallible she
prayed use that system I would say just
pray I don't give advice to any way late
unless they've stuffed the ballot box
well don't spend any time making up
acceptance speeches and don't get too
carried away by people's reactions the
night before I remember I went to a
party the night before I was lucky
enough to win mine and there were about
300 people there who'd all voted and
everybody I saw went like this they went
even ten percent of them really have I'm
in but that number I came face to face
with one of the girls with a nominee in
the girls Department and I found myself
and I had not voted for her I found
myself going
how'd you get this